you
[Music]
let's get started Group three okay so hi
we're going to present ISIL squared
which is identifying spam email with
seal so I suppose everyone here is
familiar with the concept of emails and
the thing is that the commercial email
vendors such as Gmail Outlook yeah who
they store all your emails in plain text
on their servers and there are new
services for end-to-end encrypted email
applications because obviously we don't
want anyone to read our emails other
than ourselves so we do for example have
protonmail and other plugins that you
can install on your web browser to have
an turned encryption on your email and
this is obviously very nice because if
it's encrypted then it cannot be
decrypted or read or shared with third
parties without you decrypting it but
there is a small catch because when we
have encrypted end-to-end emails like I
said no one but you can read your emails
so then the question becomes how can we
identify spam or phishing emails and the
current solutions that for example
protonmail uses is that you have black
lists and white lists and there's also
local filtering so it searches through
whether or not it says you've won the
lottery congratulations and it says this
is probably spam probably but this
doesn't really comply with the spam
filter because the spam filters that are
used on for example Gmail or Outlook is
that they are shifted through a machine
learning model and then it's classified
as spam or ham so in a bit more detail
you have your email and then there is a
feature extraction based on this email
and these features include for example
number of capitalized words the number
of words containing both letters and
numbers etc etc and then this feature
vector is then implemented into the
machine learning model and this is based
on for example logistic regression but
also other models being used and then
once the future vector has been shifted
through the model then it's classified
as per maja and this is a fairly
straight forward operation so one
question is okay so if we have encrypted
emails then why can't we just you do
this ourselves if it's so easy and there
is a problem with this because if
everyone sort of starts building their
own spam filter for their own personal
email then it's not going to be very
accurate because you have a very small
data set for training your spam filter
so the machine learning algorithm is not
going to be very precise compared to the
massive amounts of machine learning
algorithms that other vendors have
because they have much more emails to
train the models on so this is not a
very good solution then you have another
solution which is you have this large
corpora of spam emails available online
that you could potentially use to train
your own spam filter machine learning
model on but the problem is that this
turns into a one class classification
meaning that you train your model on
just one type of data when you're
actually wanted to distinguish between
two so this solution even though it
solves the problem of having a small
data set has another and it's going to
result in a lower accurate algorithm or
model just because it doesn't do as well
as if you have a large data set with
both spam and ham
emails being represented so we're
presenting a solution to this that's
also complementary to the blacklist and
in white this thing already implemented
so as Martha said there is no efficient
solution in order to check if an
encrypted email is a spam or not but we
think that we can provide a solution in
the current setting so relying on the
current email infrastructure so for
exchanging email end-to-end encrypted
we rely on existing solutions and then
when the user receives an email he first
decrypt this email and then create a
vector of features that describes the
email then this vector is encrypted
under anamorphic encryption and sent to
the service provider which can then rely
on the the model that he already has
that he trained over multiple years on
clear text email you can use this model
in order to do the in order to do the
classic classic ation of the email based
on a morphic encryption and so you
obtain a classification which is still
encrypted which design which says if the
mail is a spam or not and then this
encrypted classification is sent back to
the to the client which can decrypt and
then automatically knows if the email is
a spam or not in this case you obtain
the classification without disclosing
the content of his email to the service
provider however we can notice that a
problem can arise with this solution
because the service providers cannot
train anymore the model if they cannot
see the content of the image so if
everyone starts to encrypt their email
then they cannot update the model and
the model the model will lose its
accuracy over time and we then have to
propose another solution that will also
enable to train the model using this
encrypted data and so in the second part
of our solution we rely on the same
scenario as before so the the user
receives an email it equips it then
creates the vector with the features of
the email and this time it encrypts it
under the public key of the service
provider the all the users are doing
this this
operation and then they send the
encrypted vector describing the emails
to the service provider which can then
use this encrypted information in order
to update and to train their own model
then this model is in plain text at the
at the service provider and in order to
obtain classification we have two
solutions either the user rely on the
first solution that we presented so they
send encrypted the features vector to
the service provider which answered with
an encrypted and encrypted
classification or the model can be the
updated model can be directly shared
with the users which will use this model
in order to locally classify the emails
as spam honored and sorry so in this
case we we notice that all the users
encrypt their information under the
public key of the service provider and
they have to trust that the service
provider won't simply decrypt this
information in order to just read the
content of all the image and in order to
not have to trust this single entity we
as it was presented before we rely on a
distribution of the trust by having
multiple service providers which will
combine the public keys in order to
create a collective public key under
which the content of the emails can be
encrypted and the training of the model
will be performed encrypted under this
corrective key and then when the model
is updated and as to be sent to the
users it can be decrypted by doing a
collective decryption in which all the
the service provider collaborate so in
this case the confidentiality of the
emails is preserved as long as at least
one of the service provider doesn't
collude with the others in order to
decrypt all the emails
so in terms of performance we are
relying on logistic regression so
logistic regression in order to perform
a classification is very lightweight
it's only one plaintext ciphertext
multiplication then some rotation and
then the activation function has to be
performed requires multiple
multiplication of ciphertext but this
depends the complexity of this operation
depends on the degree of the
approximation of the activation function
so for classification it's its it can be
efficient while for the training of the
model as it requires multiple iterations
and matrix multiplication it can becomes
much more easier however there are some
existing recent work that shown that
model can be trained on a fairly big
data set under amorphic encryption in a
reasonable time and some optimizations
are possible so we can for example
update the model we can wait more time
between each update of the models only
do the updates once a day or once a week
or even more we can also optimize the
operation by batching more information
in the vector so and for example a user
would wait until he has many emails in
order to encrypt all of them in one
ciphertext and then send this to the
server and if we have the program that
the service provider receives too many
emails to classify or to train each
model from the users then you can sample
the data in order to train only on a
part of the data set and then reduce the
the complexity of the training so to
conclude we propose two solutions one
for the classification
of the image a spam or not which can be
directly plugged in in existing
infrastructure and which can be
efficient and we also proposed a
solution for the training of the model
that is used for spam detection for
which there are more challenges than for
the classification but which can still
be a possible solution and in terms of
future work we foresee already one
problem which is out to how to have
multiple providers that would agree in
order to participate in the system
because we know that is difficult to
have big companies to collaborate
together to offer one service and also
the efficiency of the solution will
depend a lot on how we pack the data and
how we set the parameters in order to
perform the training of the model seems
like the privacy of these emails are
protected by having a multiple service
provider and they are not including each
other and how do you enforce that are
those service providers from the same
company
yes or no the the the goal would have to
have independent service provider that
agree to collaborate on this task and
yeah the user would have to trust at
least one of these service provider and
all these service provider works for
your company to be trusted also the idea
that you have about future work is we
can also engage the clients as part of
the key management so imagine that you
have like now who composite kids that
part of them will be stored like in the
clients and what would say is that in
order to be like fair in terms of
computation
but this requires like more study of
course because just it sounds a little
bit harder to explore to deploy that
because involves a lot of independent
company that wishes that's not at least
two yeah yeah little comment of course
the training is quite difficult right
but um you know maybe uh maybe something
that you could do is you could just give
instead the user an option of sharing
their data and this this way the service
provider could get the training data you
know one of the problems with the
current phone apps and all kinds of
email services that one uses is that you
have no choice there's no way not to
share so maybe if you could get by
default maybe or maybe not even by
default but you could you could get this
functionality that you get the service
namely the spam filtering but then
alternatively or in addition you could
also choose to share or not share theme
yeah but like so the I can select one
problem here that if I'm using like for
example protonmail I'm doing that
because I don't want to share my data
right so I can motivate the clients to
serve the data but in the negative form
yeah but it's true that for example the
means that are indeed spam like there is
no reason to protect the privacy of spam
that we would receive so this one's for
example could be sent in clear to the
service provider to train the model then
on the other email on the other
encrypted emails and yet the problem is
do you want to share image that you
received under encryption or not so
first what's the motivation users
motivation to submit their encrypted
email to toast over to improve the
quality of water yes to have to then
have an accurate model in order to
predict if it's permanent yeah
for individuals I mean their feel emails
doesn't change much over most Kimoto so
make it like more lightweight since we
cannot train a handle like big data so
we don't have like I said like order the
data but we can periodically send like
some of the our data like because so if
you are planning to do like this like
like to implement this who will use like
some sampling in order to be able to
train on a representative sub like
trainer models and a representative
manner so I don't believe that there is
like an efficiency issue there
we can send like only one email per day
per week if you have like millions of
clients then we could still have like
good data what if a malicious client
just submit a random string instead of
honestly generate ciphertext so this
like a very good question I don't
believe that we have an answer here so
you're saying that right now the client
can actually have a malicious client
that he can choose like the data that he
is sending with us the way that he will
change the classification for for like
some emails from from harm to spam or
the opposite wouldn't like some
verification there that I'm not sure how
we cannot see that some companies like
Microsoft for example where where our
customers are mostly other organizations
and companies I mean well not
necessarily like individual users you
can imagine that companies we deploy to
some say what are whatever
Adobe some solution for me to be for
application and they certainly wouldn't
necessarily want to share share anything
but they were still want to get this
spam filtering so in these cases the
system could maybe be trained on data
coming from totally different sources
just like we can we can definitely do
that so and this is like something what
we were proposed
here is if we want to further optimize
the accuracy of our model you can try to
do some complimentary things we can
here's like all the baseline solutions
that we said that we use like different
data sets you can adjust like one class
classification but like at the end so
you can at some point all are using like
encrypted email applications then all
this data will become stale so we'll
meet there is there will be a need for
like fresh data of course so in that
case we'll have like we're proposing
this solution yeah I still think that
maybe you're making it very difficult by
tying this together so close great thank
you
[Applause]